okay we're going to bring you some  breaking news from ukraine and the  president uh zolensky says a child has  died from dehydration in the besieged  city of mariopol the ukrainian president  says that the child died from  dehydration in the besieged city and  likened it to  world war ii apparently in this address  he said that the bombardment of  ukrainian cities is  very similar to that created by the nazi  invasion in world war ii of course we  know that the water supply water power  heating supplies have been cut off for  days and he said in 2022 from  dehydration in his address so that's the  very latest coming into us ukrainian  president vladimir zelinsky has  confirmed that a child has died in mario  paul a city whose water has been cut off  uh and we can't independently verify  that but that is what the president is  saying in an address